je suis place de la république à paris
je vais aujourd'hui à la rencontre de
béchir acquis et tunisienne qui
travaille en france mais qui a des
problèmes de papiers bonjour béchir à
comment allez vous on joue enfin sur le
katia vous allez bien vous êtes avec vos
camarades aujourd'hui pour une
mobilisation en quoi ça consiste est
important pour vous nous mobiliser bien
sûr c'est aujourd'hui c'est le
rassemblement hebdomadaire de la
coordination 75 des sans-papiers chaque
semaine on est ici à la république c'est
un combat pour la régularisation et pour
la dignité des sans papiers la rente
semaine c'est important pour mobiliser
aux côtés de béchir a oui c'est très
important non seulement à travers la
litote aujourd'hui j'ai le considère
comme une serre elle est tunisienne moi
je suis malien mais on a fait pas mal de
choses ensemble c'est quelqu'un de
dynamique quelqu'un de courageux c'est
quelqu'un d'extraordinaire
[Musique]
béchir à vous allez venir avec nous vous
avez nous raconter votre histoire
d'accord ça marche
béchir a raconté moi à quel moment est
venu en france je suis revenu en france
en juillet 2015 c'était pour un stage
comme étudiante j'étais doctorante en
tunisie en histoire je prépare une thèse
disant visa touristique ne pour itunes
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de
rester en 2011 quand il ya eu entre
guillemets le printemps arable on disait
avola finalement on aura du travail
finalement beaucoup de choses vont
changer on a senti que la révolution
elle était volée de nos mains il y avait
une très grande déception quand j'avais
la possibilité de venir ici dans le
cadre des études je me suis dit moi je
vais changer de 4
est ce que vous avez connu des
désillusions par rapport à ce que vous
imaginez de la france le problème
c'était par rapport à la situation
administrative
pour résumer je suis resté six ans
commande y en a en france sans papiers
sans papiers c'est à dire son document
d'abord ça nous met sous une pression
psychologique tout le temps qu'on se
sent menacée tout le temps on est comme
si on a commis un crime voyez la
deuxième chose c'est que on se bat
chaque jour pour être régularisés par
exemple pour moi c'était un combat de
six ans pour d'autres camarades un
combat de dix ans parce qu'il faut
remplir à un certain nombre de critères
pour être régularisés c'est un combat en
fait juridique un combat où il pourra
avoir un travail un combat pour vivre
dignement aussi pour avoir un logement
c'était le commencement de la traversée
de désert pour moi
votre situation béchir à comment on fait
pour trouver un logement entre 20
travail puisqu'il faut des papiers pour
ça au début j'avais
une amie de la faculté qui habitait
montreuil c'était pas le pur hasard vous
voyez on a essayé de créer un réseau de
gens autour de nous à qui je peux aider
à qui je peux proposer mes services par
exemple j'avais de la chance de tomber
sur des employeurs qui vraiment ils
m'ont embauché ils m'ont déclaré jamais
été exploité moi par exemple au travail
moi j'avais de la chance que j'ai eue de
mes amis qui m'ont louer leur
appartement ils m'ont donné aussi 10 pts
ans de loyer j'avais pas ce problème de
ce côté-là mais à certains moments j'ai
que j'ai perdu ce logement suite à la
crise sanitaire pense qu'il n'y avait
pas assez de travail pour vous envoyer
maintenant je suis dans un autre et
viennent donc vingt foyers aux femmes
pour être régularisés comme salarié il
ya un certain nombre de métiers qu'on
peut exercer bâtiment restauration
aide à domicile ménage nettoyage moi je
voulais bien exercée par exemple quelque
chose qui va avec ma formation initiale
mais là je suis obligé de faire un
métier bien déterminé parce que j'ai été
régularisés comme auxiliaire de vie
comme aide à domicile et pas autre chose
et pourront renouveler mon titre de
séjour qui est de canon je dois rester
dans le même
de mes métiers et comme salarié ans
précise bien on peut loyer à domicile un
an on est toujours dans sous la pression
parce qu'il faut prendre à nouveau
rendez-vous pour déposer un nouveau
dossier avoir un récépissé attendre le
renouvellement on sais pas qu'est ce que
ça va passer par la suite il ya toujours
cette attente le chat ça doit être
difficile de poursuivre de tenir dans
ces moments là que vous vous en sortez
exactement c'est très difficile mais on
peut tirer la force parfois de la lutte
du combat j'ai participé à la marche des
sans papiers la voyez la marche des sans
papiers 2020 on est arrivé le 17 octobre
à paris si on était 60 milles sur les
rues de paris ce qu'il y avait par
rapport à la crise sanitaire en espagne
en italie et avait régularisation des
sans papiers en france y avait rien du
coup les sons savas qui sont sortis pour
dire régulariser nous c'est une crise
c'est comme une guerre
mais chez ac la campagne présidentielle
ses annonceurs parle beaucoup
d'immigration ça vous inspire quoi il
faut pas avoir la mémoire courte qu'ils
étaient aux premières lignes pendant
cette crise sanitaire qui s'était les
les gens qui travaillaient dans le
nettoyage les caissiers les éboueurs les
livreurs les migrants saas apporte
beaucoup de choses en france soit
économiquement culturellement
beaucoup de migrants seront des familles
en des enfants qui vont à l'école
beaucoup de migrants travaillent c'est
des travailleurs je crois qu'on doit
rectifier ses propos parce que les des
secours s'en sent pas vraiment forcément
la réalité des choses